puis bing google ou yahoo jour bruno le
maire a quand même été clairement donné
hier à new york on n'a donc pas trop
d'attentes aujourd'hui à trop d'attentes
effectivement on voit que les positions
restent très tranchées de part et
d'autre chacun en gros se renvoyant la
responsabilité de la crise actuelle
petit élément nouveau les américains
disent qu'ils ont reçu une réponse
écrite à leurs propres propositions
écrites la semaine dernière envoyée aux
russes alors là encore pas d'accord
entre les deux parties puisque les
russes se disent non en fait c'est pas
oui on a fait de réponse écrite mais
c'est pas une réponse aux questions
américaines
c'est c'est un écrit en quelque sorte
pour opposer davantage de questions pour
demander des précisions sur ce qu'écrit
les américains cette dernière voyez que
là on est dans la dans la sémantique les
russes notamment veulent avoir des
précisions sur le concept
d'indivisibilité de la sécurité sur le
continent européen que proposait les
américains la semaine dernière donc dans
quelques heures anthony blinken et
sergueï lavrov vont avoir tout loisir
d'essayer d'éclaircir sa fait pour ça
que avant ce coup de filet américain ont
fait que les russes pardon on fait des
quand même des des débuts de réponses on
va dire même si pour poser des questions
supplémentaires comme ça ça va permettre
à sergueï lavrov de dire bon bah la
semaine dernière vous vous disiez ça
qu'est ce que vous entendez vraiment par
là et c'est donc peut-être un petit
espoir que ça avance un peu mais c'est
pas gagné on verra bien alors pendant ce
temps là
à kiev cet après midi on sera avec
gulliver craag à tout à l'heure pour
voir ce qu'on attend en ukraine 2-2 ce
déplacement premier nice britannique qui
va réitérer son soutien au président
volodymyr zelensky il compte aussi at-il
dit discuter avec vladimir poutine d'ex
possible pour lui demander je cite de
reculer ce sont ses mots londres disons
le clairement bruno qui est complètement
sur la ligne américaine aujourd'hui est
ce qu a tendance à plutôt agacé et les
français les allemands aussi oui parce
que sur le continent européen et au sein
de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui maintenant que la grande
bretagne a quitté cette union européenne
après le break si tu es bien les deux
acteurs majeurs diplomatique en
particulier sur le dossier ukrainien
puisqu'ils sont donc impliqués dans le
le processus des accords de minsk et
bien les deux principales puissances en
allemand ce sont la france et
l'allemagne or qu'est ce qui se passe en
fait c'est que ces deux puissances ont
un peu de mal à retrouver leur
leadership sur cette question européenne
ils sont pas aidés par la volonté de la
demi-heure poutine de les tenir à
l'écart est par ailleurs ils sont quand
même obsédé par le fait de tenir une
position un peu médiane entre une
attitude américaine qu'ils jugent un peu
va-t-en guerre est un peu excessive et
une attitude russe qu'il cherche
également à contrecarrer la grande
bretagne de boris johnson n'a pas ce
problème et on se retrouve un puisque
maintenant c'est une puissance
souveraine autonome d'une part et on
retrouve donc un peu ce qu'on avait vu
pendant la guerre en irak c'est un peu
un camp anglo américain avec londres et
washington très très unie sur la sur la
même ligne si vous voulez et un camp
continental européen si vous voulez qui
veut plus être sur une position
médiatrice à cela vient s'ajouter la
difficulté qu'au sein de l'union
européenne tout le monde n'est pas très
unis puisque certains pays d'europe de
l'est sont plus sur la ligne britannique
que sur la ligne franco allemande si
vous voulez et boris johnson lui profite
un peu tout ça donc aujourd'hui yves à
kiev il va réaffirmer un fort soutien au
président et lenski la grande bretagne a
annoncé qu'elle envoyer des armes anti
char à l'ukraine donc fort soutien et
même lecture que washington la russie
prépare bien une invasion de l'ukraine
la menace est imminente donc il faut
réagir fort et une diplomatie très très
bruts sans beaucoup de nuances quoi
alors que paris et berlin ont encore une
fois sont sur une ligne un peu
différente officiellement on dit que
l'unité occidentale et là nous
reviennent dans les faits il y en a
quelques-uns qui jouent aussi leur
propre leur propre jeu